talks a lot about or maybe not a lot but
you started talking about Bitcoin given
the recent crash and and kind of the
economic situation etc what are you kind
of thinking about that today and I think
you even had some Bitcoin but sold it at
some point is that right yeah I did it
in a fund so I didn't own it directly
but I got rid of the fund before I do
this this business started I just got
rid of it for Bitcoin reasons not for
not for coronavirus reasons but I'm no
expert on bit going on no and I wouldn't
give you financial advice even if I were
but I'll just tell you what I did what I
did was I held Bitcoin as sort of the
hedge because seemed like it might go up
I laughingly said that I was going to
own it to stop other people from getting
rich without working because I was
watching all these people getting rich
without working and I thought well I
could stop that right now I'll just I'll
just buy a bunch and it was the last day
I went out basically I mean it's bounced
around but and I actually sold it for
right now twenty or thirty percent gain
when it was it popped up for a little
bit but it never really was the Bitcoin
of old it wasn't the Bitcoin that was
you know doubling every few days or
whatever it was doing so yeah in in a
jokey way I say I killed Bitcoin by
buying it and I actually announced it
when I did it I actually said this is
the end of Bitcoin and I just bought
something I wasn't even joking because I
think I somehow an uncanny ability to
sense the end of a good thing sometimes
I realize that and sometimes I invest
but I have this uncanny ability to say
yeah and now is the time Oh
based on my experience what I'm saying
now is the time that would be a good
time to reconsider being in this at all
so I knew I was getting in late took a
little game got out I don't recommend
you get in it or get out I was I was
interested to see if it tracked gold as
a you know a safe harbor but it didn't
and it didn't do it in such a visible
way that it would be hard to me
the argument that it's a safe place to
put money in a crisis it's definitely a
different place to put money so if
you're just somebody who wants to
diversify you could make an argument for
diversification but I'm talking about
five percent of your portfolio not 50
percent so that's the only financial
advice I'd like to give as
diversification because that's
universally just always a good idea yeah
so the one thing I think that it's not
so much convincing people the one thing
that I think is happening again kind of
how you cap yacht and say not with 100
percent certainty but I think that the
liquidity crisis that a lot of the
investment community has gone through
over the last really two three weeks I
did this research on what happened at
gold in 2008 and gold over the summer of
tails and they went down about 30
percent but it ended the crisis up from
kind of start to finish up about three
acts and what it looks like when you
kind of look with hindsight bias and you
know 20/20 visions you know in hindsight
is that the liquidity crisis anything
with a liquid market got sold everything
went down and kind of value as those
sellers tried to exit but then when the
government responded with all the
monetary stimulus etc people then ran
back to gold right and kind of ended the
crisis up again history doesn't always
room but that's that's opposite of the
guy who was supposed to work here gold
should have gone up during the crisis
but when the government made good moves
to end the crisis gold should have gone
down but it went up so that tells you
it's not a safe storage in the emergency
it's just operating the same as stocks
in the in your example I'm not giving
anybody advice here I want to be clear
on that I'm just saying that your
example proves that gold is not a safe
storage it doesn't prove the opposite
yeah and I think my point here being
that you know if you kind of look at
what's happening now right what happened
in 2008 liquidity crisis big gold
drawers down we're seeing gold draw down
again now it's down you know 10 12
percent whatever it is bitcoins
obviously down
about 50% so again it doesn't mean it's
gonna happen again but it looks very
similar to kind of that liquidity crisis
in 2008 so you know we'll see what
happens but how do you think about your
other investments so take out the highly
speculative stuff like a Bitcoin etc how
do you generally think about investing
given you know you've got kind of
multiple income streams and building a
business and books and all that but it's
be interested how you at least frame
your why's think about well in terms of
stock investing diversification is the
only word I like to use and it's the
only thing you need to do so if you're
buying a an unmanaged stock fund or a
spider as we called it's a different
form but if you go for a low fee you
know large grouping of stocks that you
can buy it with one purchase and you own
the whole basket if it's a broad index
like the fortune 500 that's that's where
I put most of my money then you you have
the same fate as the country basically
so you you wet your success financially
to the United States so if the United
States does well you're gonna do well
guaranteed it can't go any other way the
stock you know that basket of stocks
just moves with it with the country now
historically that's always been a great
investment now of course you know the
person who invested in that one stock
and they made a lot of money and you
think well I can do that too no you
can't no you can't but if you don't
believe me because you know cartoonist I
get it I do have a degree effect in
economics and the MBA as I said earlier
but if you don't believe me just google
it for yourself do a little research
should you as an independent investor
buy individual stocks a hundred percent
of experts and again this is rare to get
a hundred percent of experts in the same
place but a hundred percent of experts
will say now you shouldn't do that
because you don't know anything about
these companies these are that's a risky
thing to do there are some exceptions a
company like Apple or Amazon or
Berkshire Hathaway they sort of operate
like
themselves or they might have a monopoly
in the case of you know Amazon I hate to
say it but it's basically a monopoly you
know iPhone is basically a monopoly you
know not not illegal monopoly but it
works that way so if you have something
that's gigantic and and distributed and
acts like monopoly maybe a little bit of
your money there but even Apple could
have some kind of shock that takes it
out of business that didn't affect your
other stocks anything could happen
we've you know name the number of
successful computer companies that don't
exist
hello gateway computer I mean you can be
surprised even by big companies so
diversification period but if you're in
a position where you know you have a
good sized portfolio and you want you
want to see if you can get some kickers
you know with your let's say the 10%
that isn't going to ruin you if you if
you guess that wrong then you might go
into some funds of some industries that
you know will be good in the long run I
recently sold off some biotech fund I
had you know before this this ugliness
started so it was good timing just got
lucky but is biotech gonna be a smaller
industry in ten years
probably not I mean but but you should
still diversify within that industry and
I call them that the kickers it's the
thing that could go up 400% and it did I
think I had a 400% gain on that that
fund but that's rare you know I also had
for awhile a fund of the oil companies
because here's my thinking and this this
perfectly displays why people are bad
and investing I said to myself well you
know there's one thing that's not going
to change oil is going to be hard to get
and you know will be expensive supply
and demand will always need more of it
it's hard to get supply it might be more
restrictive it's the easiest investment
in the world I'm not even betting on a
individual company I've got a group of
companies of course that industry is
going to be fine except that it isn't
you know and then Putin decided that oil
should be $20 a barrel or whatever the
hell
and suddenly the shale business
collapses and the industry starts you
know melting now could I have seen that
coming maybe some people were smarter
and saw coming I maybe it's possible but
it was a hard one so that's why it's so
important that even if you're getting a
little you know 10 percent of your
portfolio if you're putting in these
even funds of an industry that's the
most solid industry you've ever seen in
your life
can all change tomorrow so that's where
diversification is your friend